hey guys this is andrew for
trainsenses.com i'm a professional
trader and i've been working for several
big investment banks like hsbc or
commerce bank
and i've just started to make some
youtube videos where i want to share
with you guys all my experience and all
the
different techniques that we use at work
used by pro traders
to make money on the markets so if you
want to know about how we do this
and different tools that we use you are
in the right place
so today i want to talk about the crazy
thing that happened in the market
yesterday and the day before on gamestop
because this is just insane and i want
to explain to you guys all the
mechanisms that are behind and you're
going to see
that if this stock has been chosen by
the game stoppers let's call them like
this
it's not a surprise let's get into it
[Music]
so here you have gamestop alright so
this stock
is basically selling video games and
some computer softwares
for the past 20 years or maybe even more
and you can see the trend
is just like going lower for the past
five years all right
and i added here some interesting
information that is
uh the earnings so you can see that the
earnings are not doing well the earnings
are going down together with the stock
and you have also some other very
interesting information that i'm going
to tell you about which is the short
interest
that you have on this stock which is to
me the reason why
we had this short squeeze so let me
explain to you guys how this works
and what happened here actually so the
story
is actually started on this firearm
which is reddit so which is a
american firearm where you have around 2
million people that just discuss
their views and they can choose some
stocks and they decide to put all the
money
together to create a short squeeze you
can see the kind of
message that we have here you have for
example this peric battle
which says the year is two or thirty
wall street bets is the largest hedge
fund on earth
analysts score reddit for the hottest
memes stocks are made to only go up
life is good sounds funny right he
is actually here making a joke he's been
sarcastic he says stocks are made to
only go up
you can see the mindset of those people
all right they just
feel like money is power and they feel
that now the power is on the side
and they feel good about it you have
also this girl alexandria
that says something interesting she says
gotta admit it's really something to see
wall streeters all right so guys like
you know bankers
hedge fans with the long history of
treating our economy as a casino
that's maybe kind of true complain about
a message board of posters also treating
the market as a casino
and she concludes saying anyways thanks
to rich so you can feel
that she wants revenge she wants to take
the money back from the rich
people she says like hedge funds or
asset managers
and to give it back to the small money
investors all right so
once again you can feel the mindset
right those guys they are thirsty for
blood
they want to destroy hedge funds and to
take
back the money so to me it's kind of a
financial revolution that started that
day
even the the the name of the the stock
they
they chose to do this is very
interesting
game stop right they want to stop the
game
that is happening for the past you know
20 50 years i don't know
and they want to invert the powers and
they actually did it
very well on this stock they created
this
short squeeze and this is what i want to
discuss with you guys i want to explain
to you
what is the mechanism behind why this
stock
has been able to go that high the reason
is actually the short interest so i
added the short interest here it's this
curve
and you can see that here you have some
spikes all right so you have people
shorting it all right
and here it started to go higher all
right so
i'm not sure you see it very well you
can see that basically they started
to uh take more and more short positions
around this level
and the short interest reached 60
million shares so it's around maybe 50
60 of the total share floats so it's a
lot
so means that uh 60 of people uh who
uh have these shares lend it to some
people like hedge funds so they are able
to take profits
if the share goes down so this is called
a repo contract in this kind of contract
they basically pay the reaper rate which
must be around 5-10 percent so the guys
who are selling the share
and they can benefit from the downside
movements
but you have two problems when you are
on this
short side if the lender suddenly
decides to uh
call back the share which is allowed any
time in those kind of contracts i can
tell you each time it's like this you're
not allowed
to sell a share if you don't have it but
if the
lender is actually asking you i want to
get back my share because the price is
interesting for me to sell for example
at this levels you have no other choice
than giving back the share to him
and to cover your short position you
cannot keep the short position if you
don't have the share
on your account anymore so this is one
of the reason you have this short
squeeze is like some long position
lenders that decide to take back the
share to sell it
uh so they locked the profits and the
short um
the the guy that took the short position
needs to buy it back
you have another reason all right and
that's why i think that some
very classified and private information
are on this forums all right guys some
small hedge funds
or any edge hedge funds the way it works
when they take
a strategy is that have they have a
maximum loss above
which they cannot go so if they reach
the maximum loss so maybe at those
levels around 15
then they have no other choice than
closing the position they are forced to
buy back the shares
so you have two reasons for those short
positions to be closed
is either there is a callback of the
share by the lender or
you reach the maximum loss and those
tourism combined
make actually a short quiz possible and
this is what happened here
and when the short squeeze happens guys
it's very massive
we're talking about eight thousand
percent in a matter of a few months all
right and in a matter of few days
it was two thousand percent all right
guys so this is what we call a short
squeeze so technical analysis could help
you here as well
because you can see that here we have
this uh downward sloping treadline that
has
been uh that was resistance has been
reached retested and then we go higher
so technical analysis is still working
here of course because this is
the analysis of flows and what better uh
situation to analyze the flows where
actually we're not talking here about
gamestop we don't care
gamestop is just used by those invest
investors to
uh put their strategy in place so you
have what we call a short squeeze guys
and to me this is very interesting to
notice that you know what is happening
right now
is something very unique something we
haven't seen happening on the markets
before
this is to me the beginning of something
that can go
much bigger and i think that we're gonna
have more uh stocks that are gonna be
targeted
so once again uh i think that some
people they have some inside information
and they share it here because they know
which hedge fund is actually showed all
right
uh and they know which hedge fund needs
to uh close the position before the
others
so they're gonna attack the stocks that
have massive short interest
uh especially those involved involving
some hedge funds with tight limits
and then they are able when they put all
their money together to actually force
those hedge funds to close the position
and they put
them down they destroy some hedge funds
and they feel very good about it
so they're going to keep doing this to
me this is only the beginning
and i think that the next uh stocks
we're going to see
doing this kind of crazy moves for
example amc or clds because
they have as well some very big short
interest i checked that they have around
30
40 of short interest so the same
situation
is likely to happen so if you guys want
to know
more about the different potential
targets
uh you can just check it here i'm gonna
do it as well i'm gonna try to share
with you everything i find on this
and analyze if the situation might
happen too alright guys
so i hope uh you understand better what
is the show squeeze and
how uh what are the mechanisms behind
why uh
this kind of situation can happen only
on a few stocks that have a big short
interest
and once again uh i'm gonna try to share
with you everything i see about that
and and to to keep you updated so if you
guys enjoyed this video please don't
forget to click
the like sub and bell button so you're
gonna be the first to know when i upload
anything new
and stay close to show i see you guys